uh all right we have a quick update on
Jamie foxxy and his daughter uh Corinne
will host a new game show called We Are
Family according to Fox Entertainment
the Oscar winner has been out of the
hospital for weeks according to a
message from her on Friday there's been
a lot of questions about his health Fox
was of course hospitalized back in April
for what Corrine Fox described as a
medical complication we still don't know
what made him sick but their new game
show is supposed to begin next year
which in Jamie Foxx all the best I'm
just glad that he's making future plans
we still don't know we just want him to
get better and he's making future plans
that's right that's excited about that
love you Jamie all right uh the show may
go on for the Tony Awards which
celebrate the Best of Broadway the
ceremony scheduled for June 11th was in
doubt because of the ongoing writer
strike well last night the writer's
Guild of America issued a statement
saying it would not pick at the Tonys
the wga says organizers told the union
they are altering this year's show to
conform with specific requests from the
wga according to the New York Times the
revised broadcast would include the
presentation of key Awards and live
performances of songs from Broadway
shows but no new material by
scriptwriters the Tony Awards are
televised on CBS and streamed on
Paramount plus both owned by our parent
company Paramount Global it's important
because these shows get a lot of
publicity by being on the Tony award wga
also represents writers here at CBS News
who are not on strike meanwhile striking
writers are getting support from
children check this out these letters
shared on social media from students at
St Timothy's Catholic School in Los
Angeles I love these kids one of them
says you deserve more money after all
the great movies you made another one
says stay safe don't get run over the
strike will and soon keep going and my
favorite this one says AI sucks I miss
Kimmel writers rules
I know wonderful
as kids know exactly what they're
talking about they do know uh all right
so we're looking ahead Nate to your
interview with former president Barack
Obama in our next hour before we get
there gotta talk about that tan suit you
wore for the interview let us show our
audience the moment the two of you met
check this out oh hello sir Mr President
good to see you how you doing sharp soup
oh thank you this is my Barraco Brown
you know what I love you know how is it
you get away with the tan suit and I
don't man they gave you hell for that
they sure did
oh
[Applause]
okay
there's only one question left to ask
who wore it better show that picture
okay okay Mr Nate B I love that he
appreciated the joke Nate he sure did I
love that and I'll let the internet
decide but stick around
[Music]
I have to save Vlad GTA is actually off
today but you know who's gonna be so
sorry they missed that Vlad Gautier
yeah but we have special agent chin oh I
like that I like the sound of that what
kind of skill do I have that's good I
don't know already got the skills right
now yes last Shuffle but actually uh you
know what we'll wait till the commercial
break through that okay so you know the
music start with your next mission
should you choose to accept it can't
wait the official trailer for Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one
starring Tom Cruise has just come out
take a look
after you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too
anything
there's no place that I won't go to kill
you that is written
ignores your story yeah he did run out
of road right there uh Cruz again plays
Ethan Hunt and his most dangerous
Mission yet tracking down a new weapon
that threatens Humanity before it winds
up in the wrong hands oh my gosh I feel
like my heart is racing just watching
this but Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one hits theaters July
12th it is produced by Paramount
Pictures which is owned by our parent
company I see the excitement right here
no Tom Cruise is a Bonafide of course
and every time he does another mission
impossible I can't wait to see and he's
on fire right now yes fire it's 16
million plus Americans watch this
trailer in less than 24 hours I watched
it a few times myself it's like they
took highlights from a bunch of movies
and put them into one thing and you're
like no that's all actually from now
once it's thrill after thrill after
thrill and who's putting this up what
theater I would say Paramount Pictures
by the way not just one but two
installments two installments time you
see the Tom Cruise run just go ahead and
take my money he doesn't do this like
that Nate I I feel like you can't
improve take the money for this movie he
does have a very straight running style
it's pocket to ear pocket to ear Nancy I
love how you said your mission should
you choose to accept it we do accept it
yeah I'm glad you accept it all right
now to one big story big news now from
the tennis world Spanish Superstar
Rafael and Nadal will be missing the
french open this year yesterday the 36
year old King of Clay revealed that a
hip flexor injury that he got during
January's Australian Open is causing him
now to set out Roland Garros for the
first time in 18 years a 22-time grand
slam winner plans to take a few months
away in order to recover he hopes to be
back in time for the 2024 season which
he says will probably be his last
playing competitive he lives like me
playing with the kids in the backyard 36
is still young but when your hips you
need your hips yeah hoping he's back
don't lie yeah a hell of a career that's
for sure